how are you feeling about how everything
went down
um i kind of expected that this week
might be my week to go it sucked but i
felt like a fifth wheel um so hearing
that i had a little chance to stay in
the game with kevin i was like seem to
be changing his mind a little bit that
gave me a little bit of hope so having
that crushed hurt a little bit i'm not
gonna lie but i feel like i was
preparing myself i felt like it might be
my time to go this week so it wasn't a
shock by any means
you were the holder of the the secret
power of veto this season do you have
any regrets
i actually don't i really don't regret
not using it i feel like at the time
that gino and i talked about it so many
times that it wouldn't make sense to
back door marty because i think as soon
as you back door marty the showmance is
going on the block next for the next
stop as the target so it didn't make
sense to get rid of marty it made sense
to use him as a shield
we didn't know that he was going to use
gummy bears to make decisions the weak
following
but um no regrets all good i don't know
regrets now you got the shock of
lifetime uh with a surprise visit from
your mom
yes i did that was the best was the best
part
of that surprise visit
yeah i think just getting to hear that
everyone back home was watching um
everyone back home is okay they're
rooting for me i have obviously didn't
win an hoh all season so i had not
gotten to hear from my family or friends
back home so just getting to hear that
from my mom was so amazing
and it seems like she gave gino the seal
of approval
a little bit my sister going into the
game was like don't be the idiot that
falls for the guy and gets all wrapped
up in the guy she's 16 years old okay
and she put me in my place so i asked my
mom i was like what does janelise think
about me meeting a boy in there my mom
said she loves it so hopefully that's
the case
that's amazing what do you what do you
think the future holds for the two of
you once this is all over
um it's a great question i don't think
we're not trying to put pressure on any
of it i think the feelings are
definitely real the experience we shared
was so unique and i think we definitely
put a relationship to the test in that
house living with the person for that
many days 24 hours a day so it's looking
good but we're not putting pressure on
anything just kind of seeing where it
goes having fun
now during your speech you said you
don't understand why nobody has the guts
to evict betty or josh
about those two that you think has
worked so well in their favor
i don't know what goes on with those two
they've been on the block so many times
together and apart and every single time
they escape the block i don't know what
is going on obviously now it it makes
more sense to me knowing that kevin
alina and josh had a final three or
whatever kevin said in his goodbye
message to me that makes more sense but
it's just like how have we managed to
let these people slide through like this
every time they're on the block it hurts
me it really does
now you had a real obsession with the
red door you even mentioned it on your
way out of the house if you had to guess
if you had to guess what do you think is
behind the red door i don't know why i
have this feeling i had a nightmare
about the red door i had many but i just
have this feeling the red door went off
in the middle of the night there were
strobe lights there was smoke coming out
of the door and i'm i think door number
12 because we're missing door number 12
in the house i think it's behind that
door it's going to come into play
somewhere
it might be a ridiculous thing to think
but i don't know anything so that's what
i'm going with
and now what is your strategy going into
jury like will you still be playing the
game or do you plan to
let your guard down a little like what
are you thinking
um obviously when it comes down to
choosing the winner i think it's a huge
decision it's a life-changing decision
so
i would love to be logical and strategic
about it i don't want to use my emotions
because i've said the entire game
emotional players
really get on my nerves so i definitely
want to unpack all of my emotions
currently and not make like a spiteful
decision i want to make sure that i'm
voting for somebody who i really think
deserves it
so who's the next person that you want
to see
walking through the jury house doors and
who do you not want to see join the jury
i don't want to see kevin
i'm sorry i don't want to see kevin i
want kevin to win this game honestly
which might be surprising because he's
backstabbed me a couple of times but i
would love to see kev win i would love
to see helena come through those jury
doors as much as i don't really want to
talk to her right now i would love to
see her come through the jury doors so
kevin is
kevin knows who you want to win do you
think
that given the way things are going that
kevin is
the person who's going to take it
i think he has a great chance of going
all the way to finals because everybody
seems to want to take kevin to final two
everyone seems to think that they have
the best chance sitting next to kevin
now coming into jury hearing what
everyone has to say it seems like
everybody wants kevin to win so i think
that people are going to bring kevin to
finale night
and i think they might be surprised how
the jury votes i don't know
very interesting now if you could sum up
your whole experience
here on big brother canada in one word
what would it be
i'm going i'm it's a real toss-up
between enlightening and chaotic but i'm
gonna go with enlightenment it was an
enlightening experience overall
right but there's but there's definitely
elements of both for sure totally yes
totally chaotic
right on well listen um i'm so excited
to see what's happening next uh great
talking to you thanks for taking the
time yeah thanks so much for having me
you